يدي تحومان على عجلة القيادة ،
قدمي تحوم على الفرامل لكنني
لا أفعل أي شيء ،
لقد عطل uber تمامًا الطريقة التي
نصل بها من النقطة A إلى النقطة B ، وهنا في
بيتسبرغ
هم على وشك إحداث ثورة في هذه
التجربة  إن التخلص من
السائق بعد 18 شهرًا من اختبار
uber يسمح للعملاء المخلصين في Steel
City باختيار طلب واحدة من عدد
قليل من السيارات ذاتية القيادة لماذا
نشعر حقًا أن
قيادة بيتسبرغ أصعب من تلك
المدن كما هي  يعد تخطيط الشبكة القياسي
مثل أنماط حركة المرور في
بيتسبرغ عدوانيًا جدًا إذا تمكنا
من التفكير في كل هذه
الأشياء المختلفة في بيتسبرغ ، فنحن على
ثقة تامة من أنه يمكننا نقل هذا
التعلم إلى المدينة التالية أثناء
البرنامج التجريبي سيرافق الدراجون
سائق السلامة لمساعدة السيارة
في المواقف الصعبة ، وهذا يبدو
طبيعيًا تمامًا ، ولن يكون لدي أي فكرة
أن هذه السيارة كانت تقود بنفسها
بخلاف قول أوبر self-d  يتم التحكم في
كل شيء بواسطة 20 كاميرا وسبع
ليزر وتغطية رادار بزاوية 360 درجة ، كل
تلك البيانات تبدو مثل هذه الخريطة التي يمكنك
رؤيتها في المقعد الخلفي وفقًا
لبحث من مجموعة بوسطن
الاستشارية فقط 48 ٪ من الأمريكيين على استعداد
لتجربة الذات  قيادة السيارة ولا
يقتصر الأمر على ركاب السياج
شخصيًا ولا يدخلون سيارة بدون سائق ،
بل إنه أمر مرعب في تعطل هاتفي
طوال الوقت الذي
يتوقف فيه نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) عن العمل ، ماذا لو توقفت تلك السيارة
عن العمل ، هل تعتقد أن
مخاوف الناس لا أساس لها من الصحة ، لقد رأيت بالتأكيد
حوادث  بإشراك
منافسين آخرين يديرون سياراتهم ،
فإننا نأخذ الأمر على محمل الجد في الوقت الحالي
تلتزم أوبر ببيتسبرغ بدون
خطط فورية للتوسع ، لكن
هذه خطوة كبيرة للطريق الطويل الذي ينتظرنا ،
لقد وصلنا الآن إلى نقطة يمكننا أن
نخرجها مثل  يا هذه قصة حقيقية
أخبر أحفادنا
أننا من فعلنا ذلك